[Music]
hello screen junkies good morning well
good morning for us here on the west
coast the embargo is down I'm sure the
reviews are streaming out of every site
and site and Twitter just everywhere the
bar goes down for Star Wars the last
Jedi which means that Roth and I can now
review the film or reviewing it live
right here on screen junkies thank you
for watching
Ross Burnett as always a pleasure mr.
Dan Morelle thank you for being here we
watched this yesterday last night last
night and it is I will say the first
thing that I will say about this movie
is that it is a lot to process I'm so
glad we did we did there was a choice
between going live this morning and
coming back last night and taping this
review and I was very happy that we
decided to go this morning because I
would not have honestly known what to
say right after seeing this movie
because there's so much to think about
and place and just kind of figure out in
my in your brain about this movie so I'm
glad I had a night to sleep on it we can
come at it fresh today I agree and I
think that we can probably I did
probably for me it's gonna take another
viewing as well but let's break it down
here as best we can with overall
thoughts and then maybe targeting some
of the specific assets of the film and
we should say I know it's probably in
the title we will not there will be no
spoilers no spoilers this is gonna be a
really great spoiler review to do though
I will so there's so much to break down
that there's gonna be a great spoiler
review for this movie to do and even
when we point out certain aspects right
now we will come back and talk about
what we specifically mean about
particular relationships so I guess the
first thing that I would say that I
think that again this is a lot to take
in and a lot of process because not just
in terms of the length of the movie
which is two and a half hours but the
amount of beats that it hits the amount
of things that happen in the film and
the turns that it takes in terms of how
it addresses being a Star Wars movie
yeah which it is very aware of and
that's in a in a really good way and
it's also in a conversation with itself
and the audience about what it is yeah I
think when you get a director like Rian
Johnson what you're getting and I think
that's - there
as you're getting such a distinctive
style and a distinctive feel he wrote
this movie he directed this movie and I
think that it serves this movie very
very well in a lot of places I think
that there's some inevitable things that
feel a little disjointed in the same way
let's talk about where it serves it very
well as I think the style of this movie
is it's is coming you said it knows it's
a Star Wars movie and it has that
distinct thing you know that Star Wars
feel but it doesn't feel the same as the
force awakens or Empire Strikes Back
Return of the Jedi like this is very
much a Rian Johnson Star Wars film it's
not you know we're just employing this
kind of you know up-and-coming director
to kind of do a corporate mouthpiece
through whatever he'd know this is a
Rian Johnson film and it feels a lot
different than any other Star Wars film
and and I thought that that was
something that worked for the story that
this movie was telling which will kind
of I think broadly get into a little bit
later but yeah it is that kind of
duality that I think takes it to a lot
of heights but I think also can work
against it at times yeah so here's what
I would say in that it is a Star Wars
movie it fulfills that promise right it
is visually stunning there are some
really terrific action sequences yeah it
plays with the questions that Star Wars
raises and I mean that both specific
questions that have been laid out in the
franchise and then the larger questions
that Star Wars asks kind of about your
place in the world humanity light and
dark good and bad the larger questions
of life like it's it's a very it's a
spiritual franchise in that way and I
take that with a grain of salt and I
would say this is probably the most
spiritual Star Wars film
well me well it certainly plays into a
lot of the front like the fundamental
questions that were set up in the
original trilogy it expands on those
which is really beautiful as a fan of
this franchise it delves deeper into
them and then it turns them on their
head in certain ways it is a very
humanist film it is incredibly
egalitarian it's and
think that's beautiful it even raises
sort of like political issues social
issues and all of this in the middle of
what is still a space opera right very
much that's why at the end of the film
it can feel like quite a bit has
happened but it also is a Star Wars film
in that the characters have a ton of
chemistry they're very charming there
are aliens that are both weird and some
cute some people will like the cute more
or let poor gore no pork pork pork right
like and that's okay but but in that way
that's very much a Star Wars film but it
also it addresses what it is and I can't
say specifically out which is a little
frustrating but there will be lines of
dialogue that in which you know that
Rian Johnson and everyone at Lucasfilm
is very aware of how the fan base feels
about certain aspects of this story and
the characters and it subverts
expectations which is great because over
and over again the film you think it's
going someplace and then it doesn't in a
beautiful way and that means that the
central characters which there is an
awesome core relationship yeah you're
not sure what they're going to do
because it's keeping you off balance in
that way yeah I think that when this
movie hits and it hits a lot it hits big
as far as just moments some of them
surprising some of them just for people
that are fans of the franchise I think
when this movie is hitting on all
cylinders it's really rocking there but
at the same time it it it hits but I
think it misses sometimes as well and
that's where I am kind of reconciling in
my mind okay where do I fall on this
movie because you know for its many
times it's a hit there are a few times
where I thought like I'm not really sure
what we're going for here or you know I
feel like with coming out of the force
awakens which was such a cultural
phenomenon yes
and brought Star Wars back to the
mainstream as far as like a new saga
obviously Star Wars never went
but you know the force awakens' set up
certain things set up certain characters
set up certain through lines and plot
threads that people have been talking
about and debating about for the last
couple years since the force awakens
come out and it came out and I think
that when you bring in Rian Johnson who
has his own vision there were some of
those things that he was very very
interested to delve into yes some that
he has some that he had to do and some
that quite frankly seemed like he didn't
really want one - yeah and so I I do
feel like there are some things that are
answered very satisfactorily but there
are some things that were set up in the
previous movie that are just kind of
discarded and I think that that makes
this feel a bit disjointed when looking
at it as part of an overall saga I think
force awakens to me now feels like you
know a really big adventure story to
kick off the first chapter but it almost
feels like a prologue now because this
movie kind of readjusts everything and
says like okay well you know that was
the introduction but now this is what
the story is really about and you lose
some stuff there and and and that's
where I'm feeling a little bit of like
it was a big turn that this franchise
made and I you know is everybody gonna
turn with it a lot of people are there's
gonna be a lot of people that love this
myth like love this movie if you look on
Twitter from people that have been able
to see it and do still you know on
social media there are like people that
love this movie I think there's gonna be
a lot of people that kind of get caught
in this turn and and and and feel that
it's a little bit scattered and I and
I'm a little more on that side not to
say that I didn't like the movie but
there are a lot of things that I have to
think about like I'm not sure if I'm on
board with well here's the thing about
Rian Johnson and I love him like phonic
right just is an incredible filmmaker
and I'm very happy that he is making
Star Wars movies and making movies in
general yeah he is a filmmaker that if
you look between BRIC blooper and the
Brothers Bloom each one of those movies
is a movie that's tackling a genre and
not only playing into the genre but
talking about the genre within the
framework of the film
and so when he's doing the film noir in
a high school which is what brick is
he's talking about the aspects of film
noir the characters are speaking openly
about them same thing in looper and
looper Bruce Willis sits down and talks
about well time travel works because of
this this and this and the table with
the straw and the things and if you've
seen looper you know what I'm talking
about
so he's doing the same thing here in
Star Wars and that way you're right it's
very much a Rian Johnson movie at the
same time in order there are so many
characters to deal with now right so in
that first trilogy you really care about
the there's lots of characters that
people care about inside carry lower but
there's a core three three that this is
really about and in this particular film
the core three that are the thrust and
the heart and the center of this movie
are rey kylo and luke and those
relationships are phenomenal though what
happens with them is phenomenal but you
also have all of the interest that were
introduced in the force awakens you have
some new characters and you have some
characters that are loved right exact
that are returning and it's almost an
impossible situation because you've got
to deal with them all but it means a ton
of splintered side stories and missions
there's one in particular that's cool by
the way they're cool by themselves but
there's one in particular that's kind of
takes up a good this is a
two-and-a-half-hour and it felt it a
little bit to me and there's one in
particular that takes up a really good
chunk of screen time around the middle
of the film that didn't work from it
just because it seemed like he got
painted into a corner 'he's like have
these characters they have to do
something so we're gonna send them off
to do this thing it didn't ever really
pay off to me and it seemed like there's
so much time was spent invest in setting
this up setting this up and then we got
to it and it's like well it didn't
really matter that much and and when you
view that versus the time spend you know
when I say it feels disjointed in kind
of late that that was the thing where it
felt like I have these legacy things and
people oh and new people and that I have
to bring in and I'm not you know this is
the story I want to tell but I have to
include these people so you
okay well let's have them do this but
this is what I really want to do like
this is where I kind of am struggling
with with not just going over the top on
this movie is there were some things
like that or it's just like it just
didn't quite come together for me that's
not to say that it's a bad movie stuff
to say I didn't like it but you know
it's it wasn't a perfect masterpiece for
me which that's a lot of times that's
what people want to hear they want to
hear that every movie is a perfect
masterpiece it'd be great if every move
is a perfect masterpiece but not every
movie is and that's fine that's okay
yeah I mean I think besides the the sort
of side storylines if you watch the
Clone Wars to me it felt like this would
have been the best episode of the Clone
Wars you ever know that and that's a
great show by the way and because it
allows you to delve a little deeper into
the aspects of this world which is
expansive both visually in terms of the
landscape and the culture and the
different types of society it asks
questions about these ideas of are you
born into greatness right and what does
that mean and how does war if they were
gonna be a movie about Star Wars what is
war and do you know what I mean it
really delves into what the Jedi is and
the Sith but also the Empire and the
rebellion um and it plays Mir they play
mirrors to each other um having said
that it gets a little weighty where I
feel like there's so much of this and I
think is exhilarating as a fan there's
so much of this that I'm legitimately in
love with yeah but where the story the
film just the film would have had such a
gut punch mm-hmm if we had honed in just
a little bit more on those three
characters because what he does there is
so gorgeous and what they're doing as
actors is so beautiful and he honors
Carrie Fisher very well I will say that
too that's executed beautifully as well
if we had honed in there and tighten the
film in a little bit more I think it
would have left people shattered yeah
and thrilled there were times where I
felt kind of the the the the the arm of
the law reaching in this movie a little
bit I felt like there were our friends
at red-letter me
we'd like to skewer the stuff that we do
we think it's hilarious to the nerd we
are that thing what are the things that
I love that they talk about is this idea
of like I clapped when I saw it when
they talked about Star Wars and I felt
like there were a certain number of
mandated moments that some of the movie
earns some of them I think are cool but
I'm not quite sure if it served the
movie to have them there and then we
talked about this a little bit as the
comedy which it's not just the Star Wars
movies it's kind of Marvel movies it's
it's this kind it's this feel that a lot
of those properties have now I feel like
the comedy at times was again you're at
a point in the movie and somebody said
like there hasn't been a laughing beat
in 10 minutes so put in a laugh beat
there or it some of the comedy felt
forced and it it didn't need to be there
the movie was working on it's by on its
own and and this is something that's
happening in a lot of movies right now
where this idea of like well for the
audience to engage with this movie they
have to be laughing constantly and I
don't think that's true and I feel like
maybe they thought that it was true with
this movie because a lot of the comedy
didn't work for me and it came in a
moment so I'm like you don't need it
right now
right it's not it's not an appropriate
comedy moment right now you you know
great comedy pics it's beats and fix its
moments and I felt like a lot of them in
this movie is just like I don't need to
laugh within the first five minutes of
this movie and I don't need to laugh in
the middle of a big action sequence
because it's you're doing you're doing
just fine you don't need it it's a
crutch that you don't need I think it's
I think it's a matter of what it felt
like to me is in moments because I liked
that a lot of the comedy it works some
of it really works and there were
moments where it was almost afraid to be
too sincere right yeah and that's what
it felt like to me and at that point
they would throw in a comedy beat to
make sure you understood hey we're not
we're not too sincere we're not taking
ourselves too seriously but it's letting
you off the hook when I don't
necessarily want to be a lot of fun
right and maybe I do want to it doesn't
what happens is is that you're you're on
an emotional path and then it's it's cut
off right you're not able to fully
experience that feeling Kyle is very in
his feelings but you as the audience are
not able to fully experience that
feeling result you look at those
originals three films Harrison Ford did
that a few different time
but it was perfectly executed right
because it wasn't it was very sincere
first of all yeah
and second of all it was very pointed in
particular moments I love you I know
yeah right
however in this in this film there are a
couple of times where I was like I
actually wanted to feel that what we
were what we were dealing with there I
wanted to fully experience that so I
think that that is an issue that's come
up with some more modern movies where
like it's afraid to be sincere and
that's what I mean by it's in a
conversation with the audience yeah it
doesn't want the audience to think that
it's taking itself too seriously
yeah having said that one of the biggest
things and tell me what you think that I
walked out thinking about was it isn't
possible to do a Star Wars movie it is
almost impossible there's no winning
we're at a point where yeah it supposed
to do any genre movie at this point
because you have to balance fans you
have to balance money you have to bounce
box office you have to balance the
company you have to bounce artistic
vision you have to balance characters
some of them you make this character so
you have just toy sales I don't know how
any of the movies like this ever turned
out to be anything other than a big mush
of gobbledygook I mean it something and
that's why that's what I say like well
you know it's just because I don't think
it's a masterpiece doesn't think I think
it's bad and I think that's the message
that comes across a lot in reviews is oh
well if you didn't love it then you
hated it and that's not true I have very
complicated feelings about this movie
it's a movie that I liked but it's a
movie that I also found some fairly
major flaws in that that that's not to
say that it's a bad movie it's not a bad
movie and I feel like I said that a lot
my reviews as I bring up something at it
like and then I have to say this not a
bad movie but you kind of have to do
that now overall I think that you know
they brought Ryan Johnson in to bring a
really distinctive vision to this
franchise he's done that there are some
moments in this movie that really kind
of upend a lot of stuff that expose you
to a lot of stuff that you know you
didn't think Star Wars could expose you
to that show you knew sides of things
that show you knew things that that have
never been seen in this universe that's
why you bring Ryan Johnson in he's
succeeded on a lot of those levels I
feel
there were a lot of other levels that
didn't work for me as much it is it does
feel its length if I'm being honest the
second half I thought was way stronger
than the first half the first half of
the movie I was I was very lukewarm on
no pun intended the second half of this
movie is where it really kicked into
gear for me I think that a lot of those
moments were earned I think some of
those moments weren't earned but overall
I you know I I can't fault a movie for
ambition but I can point out where maybe
that ambition failed the movie and
that's the difference it's a movie that
I would recommend it's a movie I enjoyed
I'm not jumping up and down enthusiasm
Susie a ceccolini one for loving this
movie I can totally see why people are
gonna lose their minds over this movie
my personal you know things there's some
things that didn't add up to me but
that's okay if you love this movie I
don't care I think there's gonna be a
lot of people that probably like it less
than I do that's just movies that's
that's opinion that's the spectrum of
personality that people have is people
who love and hate that's every movie
yeah I mean hey people are gonna follow
on different sides of the pork spectrum
for sure and and that is relatively
minor aspect since the Ewoks yeah going
to be so hotly contested between fans
and in the end it's sort of silly
because it's a really relatively minor
it's just not that consequential it
doesn't really matter I think they're
cute that's okay but they're not a big
deal they do it there's a great laugh in
that moment with them I will yes 100%
I have a theory about that moment that
I'm gonna tell you a little bit later
fair enough I would recommend this movie
because I think it is a it is an
incredibly crafted movie not just
visually which it is the cinematography
is gorgeous there are some great fight
coordination in this film and some
sequences that I think the fans really
are going to I clapped when I saw it and
screamed when I saw at moments and
that's partially that is largely what
the experience of seeing a movie in the
theatre is about that's so joyful when
you can have that group experience of
the big laugh or that oh my god did you
just see that happened moments so it's
delivering on that it certainly has a
lot of boxes to check and I think he
does find no pun intended the balance
in terms of being a filmmaker with a
distinctive voice and properly making a
Star Wars movie that also opens the
doors to all kinds of questions and he's
delivering an incredibly humanist film
yeah um which is what this franchise was
originally about and he twists it in a
way that brings it into this generation
in a way that perhaps the force awakens
really was that bridge yeah and now it's
entering just a new era it's not a
perfect movie it is a little bit too
long and I don't mean in terms of length
I mean in terms of like the impact of
the characters in the moment right but
as a whole I think it is a beautiful
Star Wars movie that we will be talking
about for years and years and years I
dare say and this may be a dangerous
statement that this will be more hotly
discussed and debated amongst fans yes
then the force awakens yes because I
think there's a lot in there that people
are going to unite on and I think
there's some stuff that people are gonna
have different opinions about and just
keep it keep it civil let's keep it
civil in the comments again this is a
movie that I would absolutely recommend
that Star Wars fans and just movie fans
see because there's a lot in there to
unpack and that's one of the best things
about a film is that even if you don't
universally love it and think that it
hit every single moment out of the park
and that there are things that you would
have changed that's great
it's not interesting to tell about 85%
of movies that come out are not
interesting exactly you know at the very
least you know at the very base level
it's an interesting movie so thank god
there's people like Rian Johnson that
are out there taking risks and making
interesting movies a lot of movies are
swings taking a swing with our franchise
and we're gonna have and you guys are
gonna have so much to talk about when we
can actually get into spoilers for the
philosophical questions that it doesn't
that sound fun philosophy but some of
the philosophical questions that it's
raising as well as some of the plot
points better introduce that I am
curious to see how people react indeed
thank you guys for joining us today we
will have a spoiler review on screen
junkies news that's right this weekend
it's gonna be twice this long and on it
yeah yeah let's talk about you did you
also did a catch up yes yeah if you
still if you haven't seen
or if you need a refresher on the last
seven Star Wars movies if you include a
rogue one right here on the screen
junkies there's a video called crammin
in crayon the entire original Star Wars
saga and the new movies in row 1 up to
now in less than 20 minutes check it out
mr. dameran and the honest trailer for
Return of the Jedi which I think you can
watch at the end of this video it
doesn't go live live for another 1 hour
half an hour or so but right if I'm the
end card of this video you can check out
we're completing our own saga by doing
the honest trailer Return of the Jedi
which is out now yes
we just heard from Ryan dan you are one
of my favorite people to talk about
movies with this has been a pure
pleasure thank you what's funny
this discussion will go from now till
eternity episode 9 opens in two years
it's gonna be exciting and beyond and
beyond
I'm Roth cornered on Twitter I'm Admiral
Dan on Twitter and join us for screen
junkies universe on SJ news in an hour
and a half
[Music]
you